[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 120 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
I'm mark Mandel and I'm here with my
colleague Melanie work Melanie how are
you doing today I'm doing good how are
you mark I'm all right I am slowly dying
of the flu but not slow enough that's
gonna impede me from doing the podcast
you're surviving it somehow I am mark
who are we talking to this week so this
week we are gonna talk to okay I gotta
get this right nuts dozen of ski there
we go that's dashefsky hi and Andrew
Hoying talking about for City this week
the open source security scanner and all
sorts of other cool things yes but as
always before we do that we will tell
you about some of the cool things of the
week and we will talk about our question
of the week at the end and our question
of the week is how do I automatically
scan the docker images and your Google
Cloud repository for known
vulnerabilities mmm 30 more security
more security it's all good
I bring lots of other stuff on the ml
side so we definitely got to get some
security and docker and kubernetes and
all that but anyways cool things of the
week so for this week we wanted to share
about how Shopify has moved a
significant and actually 50 percent I
think of their data center workloads
over to Google cloud and they've been
doing a number of different things
around integration for their
infrastructure in collaboration with
Google cloud so we have a blog post that
we're gonna include on our show notes as
always and you have to check that out
it's really cool yeah they are using a
whole bunch of gke and we know how much
I love kubernetes I know it's all about
kubernetes excellent okay so speaking of
kubernetes we'll go into the next one
which is kubernetes engine private
clusters are now available in beta I'm
super excited about this previously if
you're frying up a gke cluster usually
it was public ip's republic it was
available to the outside world which is
great for many workloads however if you
wanted to hide this behind a VP C or
control access through a V PC that
wasn't possible but now it is it is it
looks like you're nerds still have
access to the rest of the Year V PC
private deployments including private
access to Google managed services such
as G cRIO Google Cloud Storage and
Google bigquery and that is in the blog
post which we will again share and
another thing we want to share this week
is the easy HPC clusters on GCP with
slurm so apparently slurm is a workload
manager
and it basically is helping to launch an
auto scaled slim cluster on a compute
engine so that's what the integration
helps with so we have a great diagram of
how that works and additional
information on this blog that will
explain how to do this and we'll make
sure we share that I just like saying
slim I know Islam is a good word
I think of wood I was named to predict
seller and it shall be my most powerful
and splendid creation ever and I shall
call it slim you missed it I missed it
too late awesome so finally another cool
thing of the week there's another blog
post talking about understanding your
spending at a glance with Google cloud
billing reports beta so back in episode
number 83 we did do a question of the
week where we talked about how there
were some open and available dashboards
you could drop on top of the bigquery
expert of billing into daily studio to
give you some more introspection of
what's happening in billing now there
are actually much more integrated
billing dashboards built in to
cloud.google.com so if you want to have
a look at those those are available for
you but there's export to bigquery and
visualizing your billing data with data
studio still available so go into all
that we've just got some pre-built stuff
available at beta inside cloud or
google.com yeah it's nice to actually
see some of the trends some of the turns
that they're sharing are things like
cost group by project a different time
aggregation and including daily and
monthly views and so forth so definitely
check that out useful stuff all right I
think it's time for us to go and talk to
none and and Andrew sounds good to me
today I am very happy to have both Ned
Stoyanov ski and Andrew Coyne coming to
join us today from a Spotify and Google
respectively
the doctor was all about for City thank
you so much for joining us and that how
you doing today things work well thank
you for joining us Andrew how are you
doing doing great thank you awesome
so very happy to have you both on the
call really want to talk to you both
about for City and the project and what
it does but before we do that well you
tell us a little bit about who you are
and what do you do an ad why don't we
start with you yeah
so as you mentioned my name is not and
the work is a stab security engineer at
Spotify so that controls a lack of
security stuff and yeah I don't think we
have that much time so that I can go
through all of them but security people
listen Andrew yes I'm a senior security
engineer on Google security and privacy
organization
my team's focused on securing Google's
use of Google cloud platform both for
internal services as well as public
facing services fantastic all right well
so we brought you within today because
we wanted to talk to you both about the
for city project why don't you tell us
from your perspective and then we'll
come back to you tonight about like what
is for steady like at a high level what
problems it trying to solve what does it
do sure so for studies about making
cloud easier to secure at scale it's
relatively simple for an individual to
secure one project or one environment on
cloud or ten environments but as you
scale to a hundred or a thousand or even
10,000 environments becomes very
difficult for even a team of people to
maintain security across all the
disparate settings and configurations
that we expose for cloud so for studies
really about enabling security teams and
enterprises to feel comfortable and
confident that they're running all of
their different projects in a way that
meets their security policies and their
security configuration expectations then
that on top of that I think it's also
about having the possibility to scale
towards a national organization and have
those notifications and make people
aware of difference configurations
they're making in an actually agile
environment so that you're on top of
their stuff as soon as it happens or
close to do at that time
and so no not since you've used for SETI
I think one question that's coming to my
mind are what are some of a common
challenges that you would have for
dealing with securing something at scale
is a really good question so to start
with I mean yes we've used for SETI but
we also collaborate with Google on
actually making percenter what it is
today
and of course the goal was in a modern
environment with a huge amount of
servers you actually want take care of
the servers and what is happening on
them and on top of that of course since
it is a cloud the cloud also comes with
a bigger complexity than having stuff on
there metal and in your local
environment because you're on up using
multiple features from that cloud so one
is yes moving to a new platform and
having that secured and the second piece
is of course how do you scale your
security with the speed of iteration
that you want to have in an agile and
bar so that is kind of how we ended up
using for setting why why we actually
decided that it is a good thing to
collaborate with Google because we had
one perspective on what we were missing
or what we want to have as a tool and
then Google had another perspective so
having those children and of us having a
good tool to do what we need to do in
the cloud so that probably segues quite
nicely into like so what was the what
was the history here where does this
project start how did this collaboration
come to be sure I can I can take that
from Google side and then having an odd
fill in internally we had started using
Google cloud platform here at Google
obviously as soon as we launched it as a
product and we had quite a large
deployment on cloud even as the security
team was getting spun up so we had a
need to sort of inventory everything
that was currently deployed on cloud and
gets sort of a baseline configuration
and then as we've defined security
policies we needed a way to notify
different teams and project owners that
they needed to modify a configuration or
make some setting change in order to
comply with our security policies so we
needed some way to scale very quickly up
to a very very large environment so we
initially developed some internal
tooling to allow us to do that but at
the same time we were hearing from the
customer engineers and our professional
services organization that customers
were running into the same issue where
they've deployed on cloud but now they
need some way to monitor and manage
their environment so we collaborated
security
collaborated with professional services
and a few other teams within Google to
start putting together this framework
for what became for setting and at the
same time we worked with our product
managers to look for some of the large
organizations who were already on Google
cloud who might want to collaborate on
this and Spotify step forward and
because they were building similar
tooling and then Todd said and it ended
up being a great working relationship to
have both an outside perspective and our
inside perspective on how to build a
tool like this does force it come from
Norse mythology yeah so we went through
a long naming session which was really
was this really rather entertaining and
we had names from all over the board but
one thing that we liked about sort of
the concept of vercetti is that this is
a overseer sort of like trying to
maintain a security justice if you will
from the Norse mythology so the name
sort of just stuck out from all the
other ones that we had from choices and
everybody ended up agreeing that that it
was a great name for this product so
that's how it came about so I'm quite
curious you've both also use this term
security at scale what does that
actually mean what is that like
practically means like what sort of
things are you looking to do when you do
security at scale I don't I don't know
like exactly what that that refers to so
I think it's it's kind of along the
lines of the whole equation on how many
security engineers they need per I don't
know
squads teams and usually you can't have
that many people even if you like it and
they in the ideal world you won't have
them and the same applies for resources
it's like how many resources or how many
security engineers are you gonna put on
over seeing or checking or monitoring
resources right so it is about scaling
and it is about I think giving autonomy
to two teams and giving responsibility
to teams the build product that they
should be the ones taking care of
security when it comes to configuration
and monitoring but at the same time you
want to give them tools or you want to
give the organization tools to scale to
such size that it is gonna talk or it is
gonna notify all teams that it helped
them monitor their stuff so that is kind
of security at scale and maybe security
or self-service security at the same
time that is what it means to me adding
on to that so one of the great things
about cloud is that it enables us to
segment different workloads in different
environments sort of the evolution if
you will of computing from mainframes to
data centers to cloud as we move to
cloud we want to build security that's
sort of in from the ground up in a way
that was difficult to do in a data
center where we can run each different
workload in its own environment with its
own security settings but as the number
of environments you're managing scales
up you can't scale up people to that you
would quickly run out of resources so we
need tooling to enable ourselves
enterprises to run a vast number of
different environments without needing a
hundred security engineers to manage
them all you know so that's really what
it's about scaling up each security
engineer to be the most valuable the
most productive that they can be for the
enterprise and so for studies tooling
includes things like inventories scanner
and force or notifier is that right yes
that's correct
and can you explain a little bit more
about what those pieces damn-sure so the
inventory is simply the crawler that
says look at all of the resources that
are running in your organization a
Google cloud platform we have a resource
hierarchy that starts from an
organization node which is everything
that belongs to your organization
underneath that you can have folders
inside of those you can have projects
and inside of projects there are running
resources your virtual instances your
VMs your storage and everything else so
for SETI takes and crawls from the top
down to create a snapshot inventory of
everything that's running in your
environment and stores that and in a
cloud sequel storage currently the next
bit is the scanner which is a set of
rules that had audit the configuration
on all those resources so it might look
how your Identity and Access Management
is configure to look for like someone
added from outside of your organization
that shouldn't be as having access to a
project or look at your virtual
instances to see if they've got external
IP addresses where they shouldn't or
look at your firewall rules any any sort
of configuration that exists on cloud
and we're constantly adding additional
capabilities to those scanners so that
you can look for all of the common best
practices as well as put in place your
own custom requirements for for how you
expect things to be configured for your
enterprise enforcer it comes from
another internal tool that we had called
GC enforcer and it's its purpose today
is to set firewall policy so if you've
got a predefined configuration or set of
configurations that you want to push out
across all of your different or a subset
of your projects and forcer is the way
to make sure that those projects all
stay in sync with that centrally managed
configuration and then notifier is the
component that takes any violations from
the scanners as well as can be
configured to notify on some inventory
components as well but primarily it's
about taking a violation and figuring
out who the project owner is and sending
a notification saying your configuration
is out of sync and please fix it again
pushing some of the security down to the
individual teams instead of having
security engineers have to manage every
environment this this almost sounds like
the phrase I'm kind of thinking about it
as like as if it was sort of a terraform
or deployment manager or ansible
something like that but specifically
tailored to security so you're you're
defining a source of truth of what sort
of firewall rules or i.m policies or
anything like that what should be and
then it's up to this tool to make sure
that that is like the truth do you feel
like that's a good summarization yeah
you know we work with terraform and
deployment manager for different
projects for maintaining their specific
security and for some subset of projects
there are great tools for that because
you have sort of you defined your
configuration as code as some kind of
predefined this is exactly how this
system should be set up but as no not
said in an agile environment you also
have some
objects that are sort of being developed
on the fly or managed by development
teams or smaller squads and having a
fully managed tool isn't always best for
them so having something that can come
through and sort of audit the
configuration post post deployment it's
also really powerful and being able to
do that across all of your projects is
really the key to what for study brings
to the table yeah and if I may add to
that so there's also the enforcer piece
and that is about opening up your
perimeter to the world so that one is
about having a centrally located data
base which is the source of truth or
firewall rules which is enforced so that
it prevents people from making mistakes
that is the other piece and I think
there were there were some discussions
about maybe adding something for buckets
but then it is maybe something that is
upcoming as a feature thanks it is about
tying the loose ends nice ok so this
sounds really interesting if people like
when I use or configure or install for
SETI like how do we go about doing that
it's like is there a push button install
do i download it from github what do I
do
sure so we've got a deployment wizard
that's on github that sits alongside of
for SETI so on the website for SETI
security org there is a number of
resources including the QuickStart
installation guide but the really high
level is you start a cloud shell on a
project that you want to install for
SETI into you run the deployment wizard
from within that shell and it walks you
through everything to get your
environment set up it puts all of the
resources in place that for study needs
and spins up the VM and then gives you
access to start using it so we've tried
to make the install straightforward as
possible so that you can get straight to
configuring and using the data am i
configuring this with like yamo files or
is there a GUI or how does that work yes
it's it's all configured with llamó
files stored on Google Cloud Storage
buckets so each of the different
scanners has their own rule file that
defines your policy for that particular
resource along with an overall
configuration file that sort of defines
what resources you're reading into the
inventory and what your organization is
and
notifiers you have enabled etc well
anyway so in terms of the way it's being
used would you also use this in
development absolutely so this is a
great way for just getting a handle on
if you're spinning up some new resources
in the cloud or you're trying to develop
how you're going to ultimately deploy
your resources in the cloud having for
SETI already up and running and getting
it configured and in development
environment prior to rolling it out to
production is really powerful because it
can give you insights to
misconfigurations you know everybody
tries to do the right thing but
sometimes when we're moving fast we
accidentally leave some system open to
the internet or some other exposure that
we didn't mean to so having for study
there to notify hey you've got this
configuration in place did you mean to
is is very powerful even if it's just a
development environment you don't want
to have a security incident anywhere in
your organization no sometimes those are
the things you might not necessarily
consider I can bite you and I mean to to
add to that I mean it's usually about
taking a very holistic approach which is
yes oh you actually don't know what
you're exposing in the dev environment
or how it's connected to production
maybe it's not but in general you don't
know how it's connected to your or so
it's better to be safe than sorry
so you just focus or use for setting
wherever you need to use it but the
holistic approach would be the best at
least from my perspective and that is my
advice and yeah you just go from there
so one is one I mean you can actually
test it out in the dev environment and
how it scales up and how you will get
notifications one once it goes into
production and then the second one is
yes you also get to learn about Miss
configuration so you can either automate
them if you're deploying too many
instances or in general too many
resources and at the same time you know
what the problem is so sometimes it's
not very obvious but you get to learn
from it and this this sounds like
something you'd want to in an ideal
world you'd want to select this in as
early as possible right you don't want
to be making changes to your production
system in production you don't know
necessarily what's going to happen if
it's gonna lock down certain ports which
will stop certain things from talking to
each other or that kind of stuff would
you agree yes
solutely the earlier you can deploy it
and start getting the visibility the the
easier it's going to be to make sure
you've got all your best practices in
place from the beginning and when you go
to production you're confident is there
anything in particular you've seen
people miss when you you know we're
talking about trying to have that
holistic approach the thing that you
know seems obvious or seems so simple
but yet has proved to be one of the
bigger gaps we reckon yeah I can go from
our from my perspective and my learnings
and that is sometimes it is hard for
people to realize how different GCP is
from some competitors without
name-dropping it's not cool so and yeah
sometimes something that competitor
hasn't as an option by there's something
different in GCP so it is a big
misunderstanding to start with and then
of course the logic and the business
logic behind well not only business
logic but also the tech logic behind
GCPs totally different from something
else that might be out there so most of
those happen because of that and then of
course having a best practices and on
how things work is probably very helpful
for people I was gonna say without
name-dropping or necessary talk about
others setups is there anything specific
in GCP that you're like yeah that was
very different for us and stood out that
comes to mind one thing that comes to
mind would be maybe how buckets work or
the package gta-- storage yeah so
because yes of course you have the ion
policy and all of a sudden it becomes a
bit confusing because maybe GCS buckets
don't follow the ion model to start with
and then yes so maybe the docs are a bit
confusing what is an authenticated user
what is an org user to start with and
some of those misconfigurations happen
there because yeah it is how users are
treated okay so for said he was able to
help with addressing that it sounds like
for said he kind of takes the assumption
away right it's like you you're very
specific about exactly how things are
rather than just assuming something
works in a certain way you
that is correct but then of course it is
again up to the user to actually decide
and how their that I define the rules
right and what is acceptable to them
there are some best practice rules but
yes so it depends on how they use the
resources and how they approach the
openness of the environment where their
openness to do the world yeah I would
add to that that in general access
control policies are they're difficult
for someone who's not constantly working
with them as a security engineer you
usually just want to get things up and
running and working and so it's easy to
accidentally go or grant access because
you can't tell necessarily that you've
over granted access you can just tell
that it's working so having something
follow up and look at what the actual
configured policy is against what the
expectation is and notify people when
they have granted too much access or
over exposed a resource is really
powerful both for the learning of the
individual system owner as well as for
maintaining the overall security of all
of the environment yeah but I've seen
that be a common problem before too it's
just like I can't get in let's just give
access to everything and it's clearly
the wrong way to go but yeah it's a hard
one and I mean without overcomplicating
dancer but it's also about an internal
security culture and how open the
culture is and whether people come and
talk to the security team when they
avoid it and try to find solutions and
that is where maybe hacks happen where
people just try to solve their problem
maybe not the right way or solving the
problem but it is about solving the
problem right nice we've talked about it
a little bit but I'd love to hear more
about like what happens when four cities
find something that doesn't comply with
with the policy that's been set up it
sounds like there's two options there's
like an automated fix and a notification
because you took a little bit more about
those they're not you know you're using
this a lot at Spotify when you talk
about how that works at your end I can
talk about the ultimate that
notification so the automated
notification is depending on what you
prefer to use you have several ways of
keeping notified as a team so that can
be email slack whatever you prefer and
of course depending on what policies
you've enabled and what the rules are
for those bosses
generate violations on the first city
back then as Andrew mentioned there is
the notifier tool which takes those
violations and they adjust them or
ingest them to create an actual format
of a notification either for slack or
email and then it also finds the owner
at the same time and notifies the owner
which is yes so for example you own this
project we found a violation let's say
in your GCS storage and this is the
actual issue and this is how you fix so
yeah everything is kind of configurable
well what kind of a message juicer and
when it comes to the automated
remediation that is only on the enforcer
side of things and it is only for fire
rules so if you by mistake open
something and then you have an enforcer
enable it will reapply the rules based
on the centrally stored database or
central storage so those are the two
modes of operation can you tell us about
what's coming out yeah and this is
really a great segue to some of the new
things that's coming out here in the
coming months for for SETI there's gonna
be a new version of for SETI that's
released here the end of March early
April which might already be out by the
time you're listening to this which is
the for SETI 2.0 it's got a totally
redesigned inventory system that crawls
resources much faster so it scales to a
much larger organization than 1.0 can or
at least it allows you to take a
snapshot of your inventory at more
frequent intervals and it's got a new
component in addition to the floor we've
already talked about called I am
explainer which allows you to ask
questions like who and my organization
can restart this particular VM and it
will crawl all of the I am settings
across the organization and resolve
those to a set of permissions and then
answer this set of people and perform
that action or any other type of
question that you might have like who
can delete a resource or who all has
access to this database etc so that's a
very powerful tool especially in complex
organizations without getting too deep
into it identity and access management
policies are
hierarchical so policies can be set on
the organization or on a folder or on a
project or on a resource and the
combination of all of those ends up
being the total set of policies that are
applied to that resource so it can be
difficult to reason about without a tool
like I am explainer in addition to that
after 2.0 launches we've got a new set
of auditors and a new tool called action
engine which is gonna be a combination
of enforcer and notifier into the single
tooling and that action engine will
allow a much greater set of resources to
be automatically remediated than just
firewall rules so we're very excited
about that
that's most likely more towards the end
of June before we're gonna see that in
the product but that's that's sort of
the two big things that we're working on
right now that we're really excited to
get out and in front of people the 2.0
release candidate one is out today so
you can go ahead and try it out and
check on the website this 2.0 should be
released here soon great and so if
others wanted to contribute to force any
is there a place they can contribute yes
we very much value the community and
we've got contributions from many many
different organizations many different
open source individuals already so our
github is of course the source of truth
for our code and for study security org
has a good page on contributing and
becoming a contributor to for study and
we're always available for taking
questions there's a mailing list off of
that website as well where you can email
and we'll be very glad to work with you
on getting set up to to contribute back
to for setting awesome we're almost
running out of time but this means super
super cool before we finish do either of
you have anything you want to plug
events stuff that's going on places
people can go to learn more what's cool
and interesting with for City that
people should know about before we
finish yeah so as Andrew mentioned for
safety security the whole place to go
and check things out as me being a tech
nerd I would definitely go to github or
the github page because there are a lot
of things out there and I think they're
the resources and to add to that if you
find it interesting contribute because
it is
and Ruth you dad no I think that pretty
much wraps it up there's a lot of
exciting things that are gonna be coming
out here this year and so please stay
tuned we're excited about where the
products going so and we want to hear
feedback and we want to hear your
requirements and and what you would
think would make it better
fantastic well no not Andrew thank you
so much for spending some time with this
oh this morning or evening I thank you
for a few we really appreciate you
taking the time and talking to us all
about for setting yes thank you thank
you thank you thank you again Anand and
Andrew that was really great to talk to
you about for setting and hear what's
going on with the project yeah really
great conversation a really useful tool
for automating security especially
across multiple projects inside Google
Cloud security is always very valuable
last thing is the question of the week
how would I automatically scan the
docker images in my Google cloud posit
ori for known vulnerabilities awesome so
this is a really useful thing I am going
to totally massacre my teammates name
fellow developer advocate David I'm
gonna go with J Joe I think we need at
some point to do like a just a mix of
all of the names I'm sorry when I meet
you in person soon in the near future I
apologize but anyway David writes an
excellent most excellent blog post
talking about this so basically the
scenario is that if you're creating
docker images for something like
kubernetes or several other things that
could be potentially possible having a
way to automatically scan those for
potential security vulnerabilities is
really really useful what's great is
that Google cloud platform has a
container registry vulnerability
scanning service that's currently an
alpha that is really easy to turn on in
news it's basically an API you can go
into your API manager and basically just
turn it on and then when you go to have
a look at the images in Google container
registry you will actually see what
vulnerabilities have been found or
filling on for all of the images that
you're creating potentially with Google
container builder nice but it's it's
super easy to set up I will link to
David's blog post as well as the
documentation so you can see how it all
works sounds good
so mark GDC was last week do you feel
like a loss here that it's done and it's
over pas to me is kind of happy now
you're going to rest yeah it was great
though fantastic conference I always
love seeing a bunch of
friends and catching up and stuff I'm
not going anywhere because I'm sleeping
a lot what are you up to so on April
11th I'll be speaking about AI at
tectonic ax and tectonic ax is a program
that specifically does tech
apprenticeships with stipends and job
placement for Bay Area women and
non-binary and ult's with low incomes so
I'll be speaking at tectonic ax on April
11th and then on April 14th I will be
speaking at the Harker research
symposium and talking about diversity
inclusion and that's a suppose IAM that
does a lot of insights around tech and
diversity and it'll be great awesome
yeah that sounds fantastic well mark I
think that's it for us this week yes it
is thank you so much Melanie for joining
me for yet another week on the podcast
thank you and thank you all for
listening and we'll see you all next
week
[Music]
[Music]